[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre chers collègues
chaque jour nous sommes alertés par nos
élus locaux et par les artisans et
commerçants de nos territoires sur la
flambée des prix de l'énergie boulanger
boucher restaurateur hôtelier acteurs du
tourisme de la montagne tous sont
touchés de plein fouet par cette crise
inédite les tpeme du monde rural sont
confrontés à une hausse de leur charge
d'autant plus aiguë qu'elle supporte
aussi des coûts de transport très lourd
la situation dans nos départements
devient très préoccupante dernièrement
dans un communiqué de presse l'Assemblée
des départements de France a formulé
plusieurs demandes elle a appelé à
restaurer l'autonomie que la
décentralisation a conféré au
département pour pouvoir répondre aux
besoins de proximité de nos concitoyens
mais également à sortir de la logique de
dérégulation du marché de l'électricité
ces propositions sont légitimes et
bienvenue afin d'éviter les dépôts de
bilan les licenciements la disparition
tout simplement de la vie dans nos
territoires pas par la fermeture des
commerces de la proximité pourtant il ne
s'agit pas seulement comme le fait
l'état d'indemniser les collectivités et
les entreprises avec pour conséquence
d'aggraver le déficit public il est
essentiel de prendre des mesures fortes
comme la décorrélation du prix de
l'électricité de celui du gaz nous
produisons une électricité à prix peu
cher grâce à notre parc nucléaire et à
notre hydroélectricité nous ne pouvons
plus sacrifier notre tissu économique et
social et mettre le pays tout entier en
grave danger pour conserver quoi qu'il
en coûte notre participation à un marché
européen de l'électricité des réguliers
celui-ci s'est retourné contre nous il
nous pénalise fortement dans les
circonstances que nous connaissons aussi
le gouvernement va-t-il enfin entendre
cet appel pour la décorrélation du prix
de notre électricité de celui du gaz